[Music]
now it's moving up the multiplayer it
seems like the other side of this
two-headed dog you saw it and it's
apparently in terms of overall like meta
progression and stuff super different in
the first game yeah so I the actual
interview I had at Star Wars Celebration
was about multiplayer and the biggest
change is going to be the progression
system they're trying to give it more
longevity and trying to keep you coming
back to multiplayer and with that
they're giving both troopers and heroes
progression and then that progression
unlocks kind of customization I mean
obviously like Darth Maul's gonna be
Darth Maul like you're not going to be
like I have Darth Maul with a gun you
know but like you you're going to be
able to give them sort of a career and
then they also talked about wanting let
this quote here this is a burn dimer who
I talked to from dice and they wanted
heroes to not just be like quick pickups
they didn't really specify but it was
that he talked about a resource based
system that as you can see here gives
them a little bit more presents more
likes he's sort of described it as being
like weightier like having them kind of
occupy more space on the field and I
wasn't exactly sure what that meant but
it seems like it's going to be a little
easier or just different the process of
getting here is gonna be different as
opposed to those tokens that pop up make
sure random and I i remember when i
covered scarify like could not find the
you know jenner so like on like i would
stalk and wait for an area i would see
guys like doing the same thing it's not
participating at that point in the first
battle front row 1 dlc you mean correct
yeah yeah but yeah so did you get to see
the progression system in action was
this all just kind of them telling you
about it no this was just talking to
people from motive and dice there's we
really don't have a lot of footage the
only thing we got for multiplayer from
that trailer was just seeing different
heroes that are going to appear like the
trailer says its heroes from all eras so
yeah just to clarify people watching
this live right now this is the first
battlefront from EA and dice this is we
just we don't have much footage from the
second one so we threw this up to come
it kind of you know you pick up a token
then depending on the planet you get the
hero in this case Luke Skywalker on Hoth
yeah but as Kelly's saying it's more
tied to just like completing different
actions may be in a more battlefield
kind of way right you don't have to just
get kills to contribute to something you
didn't actually like be a support
character a healer maybe because burn
dimer who's what was up earlier he's
from dice uh I would imagine maybe
there's some sort of connection
therewith how it works in battlefront I
don't know yeah I battlefield um it
really wasn't clear and I was like oh
while our heroes specific to planets and
they were like maybe like okay um the
other cool thing is that troopers are
specific to you the location and era
you're on because they're trying to keep
it more I think he said more
authenticity the aesthetic of the
soldiers are but not that yeah loadouts
you can those are carry across planet
yes so it's basically a skin and York
that's tied to the progression system so
your career trooper is gonna be the same
you're not gonna have to like restart
because now I'm in the Clone Wars era
and now I have to start over I think
they even mentioned on their site that
they'll have separate modes catered to
like the mix and match of like Darth
Maul and kylo Ren yeah you know hit in
the town like I think they'll have at
least those step out for some martini
going on cosmos shooting the [ __ ] kylo
Ren is such a Miranda so darth maul's i
miss amantha maybe exit now carries a
carry I don't know section City to write
this is Belle front to correct can't do
couana tattooing kind of a long lasting
who is that little guy not joking uh I'm
into the more like if Count Dooku was a
character on friends who would it be oh
my he is such a Ross like I've never
thought about that until now mace windu
would be such a Monica oh just her
overall though yeah so muttering I was
like why they all there um I'm all like
they'll definitely do that it sounds
like but on the flip I would I would
really hope that they have game odor or
playlists that are you know it stripped
maybe of these heroes cuz that's just
yeah something I I personally don't
really care
or yeah yeah I really really we talked
about this every time that we talked
about battlefront two so far I hope that
they borrow from things what they did
with that will field one both them being
something dice worked on but like the
first battlefront was very if your star
wars fan it was fun for a few hours at
least it was for me but then after a
while kind of just lost its substance
and I felt like it was all just
spectacle surface appeal I hope they're
actually maybe the progression system
will help I know progression systems are
nothing new and I know that's kind of
become a staple since like modern
warfare right um I still think that
could give it the legs that the first
one didn't have I agree I mean he thinks
they think they recognize that and I
think they're taking steps to rectify
that with battlefront two but I mean I I
agree with Rob I would rather have an
option to just kind of not have heroes
although they did mention that one of
the things they they took care to do was
not make heroes feel overpowered they
wanted if you weren't playing a hero to
be able to take down here like feel like
you were on a level playing field so i'm
a little i remem not exactly sure how
that will work um I we just really need
to see more of it in action I think but
as far as what they're saying with
what's changed it seems like they
recognize the problems with the first
out front yeah we talked about last week
p and you said that you were kind of
tired of seeing like Han Solo
corkscrewing across the battlefield and
just done specifically I love no though
it was the amber doing barrel rolls
right that's what it was when Han Solo
was just I don't know what was he doing
Cindy intrigued questioning the meaning
of life dapper you're selling that
Bigfoot thing aren't ya you're still
phenom who don since then I haven't
anything yeah yeah the other thing about
the progression system to not I'm
thinking about is with the last battle
front was that everything was locked
behind a currency and that's including
you know I mean here it is the other had
hot contracts you had to basically I'm
like I think it was just too much
maintenance and work opposed to just
like you know the subconscious idea of
like the more I play I'm just gonna
unlock more weapons opposed to like all
right well I have you know 2,000 credits
whatever it is where am I going to put
that I sure saw my I'm not gonna put it
into any cosmetics I think that's one
thing you know i mean like i never got
our played as much as I what
have to the point where was like all
right you know I've unlocked I've
unlocked everything now it's time to
maybe focus on like how I look as a
storm trooper sorry I don't know
captured this but that was pretty dumb
to call that anyway you're in the middle
of the hallway getting shot he's not
dead but I'm eats baby new he's gonna
die bounce down maybe it was you
capturing it no yeah excuse me when you
get in the vehicle you disappear so I
just saved my ass oh yeah I'm in and
saying defense I forgot in this game
you're not you're immediately safe it's
a get-out-of-jail-free card you warp to
a TIE fighter that makes sense I don't
know why I'm calling out the logic in
Star Wars but it's all good it's always
been physically sound Star Wars sound
like hard sci-fi but it's the fantasy
dude yeah yeah yeah and here's space
battles and you know what's nice is like
you know criterion who made the VR
x-wing mission they get like from the
ground up reworked all the flight
controls and they felt so much better
compared to the vanilla game yeah I do
have some questions about battlefront
some from the story that again didn't
get to earlier but I Grant Wilson on
Twitter was asking do you think
battlefront 2 will keep the bad guys the
bad guys or will they switch sides do
you think they're gonna stick to that
like are you are the Empire the whole
thing or is it going to end up just
becoming this new moral gray ground it
really seems like they're trying to give
you a different perspective and not just
frame the Empire's as objectively bad
it's more like see where they're coming
from sort of thing I think it's not like
grey Jedi stuff I'm like a personnel
level probably more than anything right
yeah so this is a mark thompson from
motive studios and yeah so I'd in there
like he says here they're trying to just
kind of put you in somebody else's shoes
and it's not clear if they're going to
uh like I mean I imagined that maybe
they'll be like a come to Jesus moment
where you're like oh man the Emperor was
real bad I don't know but um so but it
seems like there's they're taking a
nuanced approach her there was it
Robbins at you not to keep making
comparisons like band of brothers but
there's that episode of band of brothers
where they're in Austria and kind of you
know or no Bavaria and they're just
saying kind of
looking at what it meant to be like
boots on the ground soldier for the
Nazis as opposed to this like Third
Reich officer and then if that's also
when like Germany had collapsed at that
point and Allied forces were across the
Rhine everything kind reminds me of
something like that the downfall I don't
know because I mean like storm troopers
and what not always being kind of like a
stand-in for Nazis here well yeah I mean
there's a difference between being I
mean like an 18 year old kid on the
German sighs the same as an 18 year old
kid on the American side you know so
it's it's sort of a similar vein but I
didn't is a commander so she has more
power than expected yeah she's she's
more than than the average stormtrooper
and so yeah maybe that'll be the
difference maybe they'll examine that
Anna I mean no it's just like World War
two like it's the series of just
propaganda and brainwashing like you're
led to believe the Emperor is awesome
what force awakens number when uh when
Finn is showing signs of kind of he's
got a poster of him on your ceiling
sleeping a good look that's something
they actually said is that the kind of
character they're trying to build here
the inferno squad which is the iden
squad is kind of like the people you
would put on the propaganda poster to
inspire you know Empire kids to want to
fight for the Emperor like that's the
kind of character they're going for so
who should ride in the chat twitch chat
I know what I'm talking about span of
brothers go watch it if you haven't seen
it just point but yeah yeah you've seen
better brothers you know what I'm
talking about if you haven't then go
watch it alright cool or i would say go
check out the sub right i think it's a
subreddit called the Empire the Empire
did nothing wrong it's like there are
people who just like skin and scour all
of the movies and just look for like she
liked look like you know the whole thing
about the Death Star that's I think this
is now not considered canon but that the
Emperor made the Death Star because
every like 10,000 years this like out
just very much for the plot of mass
effects know this way even the Reapers
come along yeah they come and they like
wipe out the whole universe for the
galaxy or even like repping for that
yeah
destroy its really funny well yeah it
was a whole book an or something like
that on I found that really interesting
I don't you know I really love the dark
side I was always a Darth Vader girl I
had a crush on Anakin Skywalker I will
oh he's dreamy I had the biggest crush
it is that's nice middle-aged is happy
when he's on musafar oh my god no a lot
yeah I have the high ground Callie the
Empire could I would sure that they did
something's wrong now you know all the
things all right anyway if you're in the
twitch at YouTube chat if you're
watching this afterwards on YouTube let
us know what you think of battlefront 2
whether you plan on playing multiplayer
whether you're excited for the campaign
whether you're excited to see things
from the Empire's perspective let us
know
[Music]